joining me now is Xavier de Rosso a
former BLM activist turned prageru
personality Xavier great to see you
tonight
um you have an interesting perspective
on this debate explain
yes I think it's important that first of
all we call this exactly what it is this
is 111 ways to Gaslight black Americans
into thinking that we need to be
dependent on a system of handouts in
order to be successful black Americans
have been indoctrinated with these lies
for far too long and I used to fall for
the lies until I took a deep dive into
the videos on prageru.com and realize
how easily debunked these fraudulent
narratives surrounding systemic racism
actually are
well right now it seems like the San
Francisco Board of Supervisors and then
the task force on reparations in
California that they are dangling the
prospect of a lot of money
and a lot of property and a lot of debt
forgiveness does this end up blowing up
in their faces
absolutely this is never going to
actually happen it is so unrealistic to
think that the average family in San
Francisco is going to be able to pay six
hundred thousand dollars extra a piece
and you know when people look at this
list of the things that they're
recommending the most alarming thing for
most is the five million dollars going
to each black person but for me as an
American I'm looking at this list and I
see that they're wanting to sell Homes
at one dollar to Black Americans as an
American and as someone who used to live
in the San Francisco Bay Area it's
disgusting to me that we are more
focused on slavery which ended in 1865
than we're focused on the veterans who
are on the Streets of San Francisco
homeless and begging for spare change in
2023 that's where they need to start
sending their money
but don't you agree that you know white
liberals just have no interest in
opening up their wallets
they never do if I went up to a white
liberal and handed my venmo account they
wouldn't send me any money but they're
the first people to demand reparations
because it's just another level of them
virtue signaling and like you saw in
some of those prior Clips people are
taking full advantage they're selling
their books they're selling black people
their own oppression because it's
profitable to indoctrinate people with
victim mentality
Xavier great to see you tonight thanks
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else